and it now why bright like you're the
boom boom boom that makes me excited now
I gotta find Ingrid I'm live everybody
how about road is doing well I'm looking
for how do I bring in Ingrid usually I'm
in the receiving end of these everybody
so I apologize uh I need to figure out
how to find her how she's gonna pop up I
know I've got a enhance here do i add a
person invite people pool there we go
there's Ingrid on bite her hi to this
video call pull it's been invited
hopefully in grid you're watching me and
laughing at my silliness of not
completely having this down since I'm I
do skype Celyn google places and these
dreams all the time but haven't been on
the broadcasting end of it hello
everybody hope everybody's well happy
2014 I feel pretty good at this point
that I've invited Ingrid who's
interviewing me so even though I'm
initiating it um so I'll wait to see
where she maybe just check email excuse
me for a few seconds just to make sure
um what's going on here mm-hmm we have
talked to my team here guys for a second
hey guys do we uh do you have you heard
anything for them or
oh my senior pop-up she I saw a pop-up
which is good now hopefully she'll pop
up live in which a countess showed up in
the bottom corner you guys see that on
your end but not her live right
no she showed up on the bottom right now
probably not in her and now it's gone
she was there for a second
it's open the chat see you a chat hello
Channing gggg apologize everybody for
the holdup I'm not sure what is exactly
happening to see Ingrid thou shalt up
again there she is oh my gosh oh hey
meant Gary you know what was really
going on I was busy reading your book
that's what was happening that's what's
going on here no offices we're busy okay
how are you good sorry everybody now
we're here I'm going to take it away I'm
good I'm good how are you doing it's
good to see you sorry everybody so I
think that's Murphy's Law here we are
getting ready to talk to all of you and
we can't get online but we're doing
great we've got a big year ahead of us
but Gary I know you do too i'm really
psyched to talk to you about it as well
thanks for having me I'm here in Vegas
at CES in a hotel rooms of a lot going
on well we've got some of our guys there
and so what are you seeing is some of
the neatest technology that's happening
at CES I saw a Dre or beats by dre he
was on TV the other day at looks pretty
interesting but he always has
interesting stuff going on so what are
some of the neat things you're seeing
there at CES you know I think it's I
think it's a level of a smart everything
right I think we're starting to live
through these smart ification of our
society it's not just the smartphone or
you know smartwatches you know smart
pants mark everything I fully expect
everything to be smart when I think I
don't think you know CS isn't what it
used to be when people really watch the
biggest things here so I think what I'm
really sings the nuances of smart
everything so Gary you know what's
really interesting I'd love your take on
this so as both of you I mean both of us
are focused on how can we really help
entrepreneurs I'm doing it through the
dell center for entrepreneurs you're
doing it through all your work in your
new books like what are some of the
things that you're seeing entrepreneurs
need most you're talking about all these
smart techno
ologies that you're seeing there at CES
but i'll give you my take on it but i
want to hear yours first you know i
think entrepreneurs need to i mean very
practically they need to recognize how
to execute right what do they need to do
for their business and it's not about
the new flashy technology its how do you
bring value to customers and how do you
price it in a point that people actually
want it I think it's actually shocking
simple you know I think it'd be really
need to give are you all hearing me okay
everything's coming through ok so I'm a
senior at the bottom I screen Gary but
we're just having a few tech things
going on here but again Murphy's Law so
we're just gonna roll with it but it's
really interesting I mean again I would
love to dive into that with you a little
bit because one of the reasons that I
wanted to talk to you is because in in
large part like what Michael Dell and
and the executives here have enabled me
and now my team to do is really focus on
critical areas that we think
entrepreneurs need help in and and what
they've told us they need help in and
that's access to knowledge which is
something you do in spades access to
networks you're an incredible networker
and then on our end of course access to
technology and then of course access to
capital so which by the way I don't know
if you know this when I saw you at the
ink conference so I was overseeing a
hundred million dollar debt fund that
fund is now 115 million dollars so we're
really super excited about that so a lot
of expansion that's going to happen this
year but we're really focusing on those
four areas and I know that you hit
knowledge and networks pretty hard and I
did go through your book Jab Jab right
hook thanks for sending me a copy of it
but what are some of the specific tips
that you can give a bootstrapping
entrepreneur who's short on cash trying
to bust out like a Gary Vaynerchuk get
their message out there don't have a lot
of money to work with what are some of
the things that you would recommend that
they do to question their so there's a
lot of things that should have done you
know I would tell you that the first
thing that people think about is how do
you do something that people actually
want I mean you can do anything you want
you can get money you know you can you
can have the best idea of all time but
if you can't execute you have no shot
twice
only way to execute actually you for
your good at so I think people put a
business that you're good at matters you
my tactics complete Michael Dell's
tactics for millions of munchkins I've
done it differently what I think they've
done more than anything is bet on their
strengths instead of their weaknesses
right so it's I think I self-awareness
looking mirror and saying what can i
bring value into the world what am i
back and then building a business around
that that is the most important part
because if you're wrong on that nothing
you do when you value so Gary let's like
jump into a specific example with you
because when you and I met the first
time which has now been years ago and
you were doing the wine library and all
of that you were creating a lot of
online content but like let's be real
about you know you're you're great in
terms of marketing and getting a message
out there but I want to talk about your
books because I have a lot of college
right now and entrepreneurs who are
thinking books as an example are a great
strategy to get their message out there
do marketing and you didn't start all of
this as an author so you know when
you're talking about focusing on your
strengths and your expertise give us a
specific example of how did you then go
from doing Wine Library and certainly
having content but then translating that
into a best-selling book give us some
specific examples of what made that
happen when you sell a book and you kind
penny on the level of success that I've
had with hooks you actually are selling
it years enhance right so the things
that I'm good at on building communities
producing good content and being a biz
dev salesman right i mean you all those
parts of matter ha I actually stole tens
of thousands of books ever cared about
me because I gave them value on facebook
and twitter before my book ever came out
yeah after Jab right hook means good
given and ask I was giving all of 2012
because I had nothing to ask for my
granny by 13 when I wanted to sell a
book I wasn't bashful type low right
hook as many of the people that are
watching here right now from my facebook
and twitter pages they know that I've
been to look like why my book I through
the right hook I wasn't scared
wampa how long did it take you to
actually get that first book out like
what's realistic to think is it a year
is it too fierce what is it everybody's
different I had a ghostwriter and I aw
do I took a phone and audio the far
majority of my content know for me that
went quickly because a lot of people
watching here know that I love to talk
so it's easy you know but for some
people that provide it they're writing
in between things the process of
producing books we both sat on it for
four years some people bang it out in
four minutes you know so I think it's a
very specific issue at hand it depends
on how complete your thought is I never
write books until I have a full 100%
complete thought because then I can see
it from coast to coast in my brain then
I know I can actually compute if I'm
only on third base then I'm like wait a
minute I'm gonna split too much time
trying to figure out the last part is to
drag forever and by the time I figure it
out in my mean I had a couple of books
in mind but I've never happened because
by the time I got around to like figure
out what I wanted to talk about it I
didn't think it would be relevant yeah
so Gary I mean and one last question on
that because you know you reference a
lot of the guys and gals that you work
within your company that were huge helps
and certainly your family to putting
those books together but then you also
reference your ghostwriter so what is
the one last piece of advice that you
can offer the entrepreneurs who are
listening each all of this who aren't
necessary is necessarily authors who are
looking for that ghostwriter to help
them get their message out there how do
they find a really great one how did you
get yours my publisher that's definitely
the one thing they did they got me a
couple recommendations the chemistry was
there with Stephanie Stephanie land and
away we went and becomes very great
blocks together and when you found your
publisher was that something that you
set up yourself or did you get help on
that on that front uh my publisher I
gave a talk look for everybody's
watching one of my most you talk on
YouTube is this web two point 0 2 off
you know stop doing stuff you all that
my talk that kind of broke me out when I
was done with that talk by the time I
got back to my office my five different
publishers are asking for me to write a
book about that talk though I then
negotiated that deal myself
that's really great advice so I think
everybody listening to this out there I
mean I always think about that content
that you're putting out there and some
really good advice to even get a first
book out there for all of you first-time
authors that are nor look the best way
to get a book out there is to put out a
few limited contacts and let them come
to you instead of you pitching a book
proposal yeah hey so Gary you know when
so here I am I i I'm blessed to have the
opportunity to sit inside what has been
a fortune 50 company we have access to a
lot of resources that we make available
to entrepreneurs and again it's a gift
to be able to do that but but to flip
that and again go back to something that
you talked about a lot which is again
give give give and ask Jab Jab Jab right
hook um what advice do you have for
those entrepreneurs who are just trying
to keep their lights on and they're
listening to you and they're like wait a
minute we got to make some money here
and this guy is just talking about just
keep giving giving giving you know what
how this is really more of a just a
philosophical question and and how do
you what's the mindset that you want
them to be thinking about to get through
those those challenging times the
alternative which is doing what you
don't want to be doing right I mean
ultimately if somebody wants to be an
entrepreneur that's the thing to do
right so the alternative mean I think
one entrepreneurs complain in the earth
but I gotta make one fast I'm like
everybody does that's how it is I was
making twenty one thousand dollars a
year like when I was building while I
but I didn't have it's not like I had a
waste I have a Kiki shake it's all
glamorous now I'm in trouble I'm not 18
years old eight I've been doing this for
20 years like I did but do you know what
I mean Ingrid like I think there's a
lack of paper very high you're like 25
yeah but Ingrid I mean listen like this
lack of patience is silicon like when
people like well what was me I need to
make money Gary I can't give I'm like
you understand that's the only option if
you just take you're going to burn out
after a couple of years and you didn't
get back into that job you don't like in
debt
you know scorned reputation what's the
alternative the alternative is not to be
an entrepreneur and have a great life
making fifty thousand five hundred
thousand a year and not have all the
stress all I mean listen gray hairs are
coming in like there's a plenty amount
of you know alternatives to being an
entrepreneur but this notion of who wait
a minute Gary I don't want to be patient
because that's what you just asked me
really what you asked me is but wait a
minute like people don't want to be
patient like no I need to make money now
well good for you jerk off everybody
wants to make money now like I want to
make money now we think the advice on
being patient i mean that's that's an
incredible point a really great point i
agree with you on that but you and I
both know i mean i've had my own days
where i was completely broke just
wondering again how am I going to keep
the lights on and it is really hard to
be pretty patient when when those times
are going on so you know I mean you know
when when did you think you had made it
what was that point when you were like
this I'm in the big leagues now it
happened hasn't happened but i also have
ridiculous ambition right listen is that
what you buy the jets let me listen I
really like that to happen I mean listen
I thought I meant it I like I equally
thought I've made it from the beginning
to not thinking I've made it now I have
equal things pulling at me right I think
I've lived it before I even made it
because i have in national but then i
all can i tricked myself to be nice I'm
great but then I equally secure right at
this moment with a lot of threes and a
lot of things under my name that I could
point you and I really feel like I
hadn't made it no that is not you know
if you don't love the game if you don't
like the climb or the process if you
don't love the process of never making
it that you're not a real entrepreneur
so Gary I know there are a lot of things
that you can be doing with your time and
so psyched when again you and I ran into
each other at ink and I was like I love
what you're doing and got to get you
involved with some of the stuff that
we're doing here Dell and I know you're
really particular about how and where
you spend your time and I want to take a
selfish moment for a second given Dells
just on private Michaels making a huge
push to get back to you know
the entrepreneur and and it's sort of
that entrepreneurial spirit that's been
at the core of the company from the
beginning and I'd love to hear and I'm
sure the audience would love to hear too
what is it about some of the things that
you've seen happen at Dell that made you
say you know this is something that I
want to be part of to what are what is
your hopes for the future in terms of
how we can really help the market your
back and we're taking goods my way
you're you're you're back to being an
entrepreneurial company right i mean
when you're a publicly traded company
and a large making decisions on stocks
icing corporate that the other thing my
hope is actually not even a hi I hope
there's an expectation to be honest with
you Michael's done it before right so my
hope is that the market hasn't changed
too much and the dynamics haven't
changed too much that it keeps you guys
away from being what ah the only reason
doing stuff with you guys now and
believe in nice now is because Michaels
back at the helm I can apply to capacity
and that makes me feel that he'll be
able to and him and all the gals and
guys around him are going to be able to
treat the company the way they want to
without trying to justify what they did
this quarter or what they are going to
do this year the way to be a great
entrepreneur and if the advantages of
being grounded are is I didn't want
complete to anybody Bailey has gone from
20 to three hundred thousand years we're
growing like crazy we're becoming a big
company but if I had a three quarter to
clutter up what I was doing I would have
never made it I wouldn't have invested
all that money up front my time or as it
was broken or lost money on accounts so
I could grow with them in the future you
make 20 of different decisions my
expectations about to put a fresh
lacquer i doing it is i expect amazing
things for your company in the next half
decade because i think you are now
playing the right game and I think that
up Michaels playback in the past he's
been able execute yeah I think both you
you know both of us have have the
opportunity to be a voice and
representative for entrepreneurs and I'd
love you know given your out on the
market with entrepreneurs all of the
time what are some of this
pacific ways that you see large
companies like Adele being able to make
a difference in the lives of these small
business owners so just like you were
back at what a Wine Library what are
some of the things that a large company
like Adele can do to be helpful to these
types of companies in your mind scale
you guys have money and scale right you
know uh Gary I swear I you know i'll pay
you later for that one cuz i tell our
team all the time like it's all about
scale you know we help people scale so
i'm glad you said it yeah i mean that's
what you have right like you know I wish
when I was building wine library when I
was 22 year old kid all I had to look up
to as my dad you know technology has
changed look what you guys are doing
right now you're facilitating you know
listen I'm not spending you know time
I'm just too busy you're able to have
the scale that allows me to do this
partnership of you guys and and bring
access and information to people i wish
that i SAT here and watched somebody
does look like me and was able to pick a
nugget here or you know I emphatically
I'm tellin all of you to be patient you
know I wish you know somebody could have
taught me the things more structured
work-life balance whatever I was looking
for at that age so you guys have access
and skill you guys can get to anybody
you have money to impact anybody you
have the ability to get people and
thought leadership to entrepreneurs we
can get to anybody so you know it's
access and scale where you guys do with
it will then in your execution will
determine plenty of people blow it with
access whiskey they don't bring people
the right stuff they think that the
money can just do it for them they think
they can by and wait to it that's not
enough it could be the right balance
between the dollars and scale and then
the content and impact that you guys are
able to bring to the table yeah and Gary
you know as a friend and a colleague and
I know some of my southwest is coming up
you're coming down right of course good
good good we're gonna have to get you
involved in some things going on here
but I'd love to have you stay involved
with some of the things that we're doing
here at the delt Center for
entrepreneurs the one plug on our side
that I want to make is for those of you
who are watching love for you to check
it out at dell.com forward slash
entrepreneurs and and truly Gary thanks
so much for pointing those things out
because absolutely the thing that drives
my work every day and the work of our
team here
is so many of us are life-long
entrepreneurs just like you and
Michael's given us the chance now to say
we're getting back to our
entrepreneurial roots how can we
leverage these resources to help these
entrepreneurs be successful and that's
exactly what we want to do and Gary your
visibility and your voice for
entrepreneurs and you taking the time to
spend with us today it's it's another
great way to help us get the message out
there and we really appreciate that
thanks again I appreciate that yeah okay
so what can we expect from you this year
outside of just the the book growth what
what can we expect from you I'm going to
keep it pretty simple this year I think
it's gonna be you know my daughter's for
my son is 18 months more family time
then after that I want to continue to
building the media I didn't expand
offices into more cities so in New York
and San Francisco now I expect two to
three more cities having offices there
were growing very rapidly and then I
want to figure out a way to triple down
on how I invest I've been very well
investing in Twitter and uber and
Birchbox and all these great companies I
I've done so well I've got to really
figure out how do I want to take it to
the next level you know whether it's a
fund or an incubator I've got a chance
to be quite well um I just uh I just
have to figure that out this year you
know and how can people get involved
with you Gary outside of of buying the
book so I did the plug for the dell
Center for entrepreneurs how can they
connect with you especially as you're
thinking about how you're gonna
essentially or potentially invest over
this next year you know what to me it's
it's pretty easy to like you know I'm
almost open like info and comments and
accessibility as anybody right or it'll
show like you know hold email me zippy
upon all contents watch all my keynote
read you all my thoughts when it comes
to like working with me or getting into
my lexicon awesome hey Gary thanks so
much i know we were going till two
central it's so great to see you again
so great to talk to you and there's a
lot going on at CES
so I hope you have an amazing time there
thanks everybody for sticking around
while we're going through so the
technical glitches always great to talk
to you Gary have a wonderful day and
we'll see you all soon thanks Ingrid and
everybody you know I know a lot of you
came here from my tweets and Facebook's
I just want to you know wish all of you
a tremendous 2014 thanks for all the
maniacs and people that have supported
in all you entrepreneurs and startups
and teachers and whatever you may be I
appreciate it i know this was a quick
chat was awesome me with ingrid think
what i was doing and work well you know
i just want to just thank all of you for
taking time out of your life to come and
sit here I know when you get to do as
much QA as I like normally do or things
of that nature but I hope you enjoyed
the few minutes were together and more
importantly I hope I I see you soon so
thanks cigarette so much thanks so much
Gary take care